Hello Freak bitches.
When you see some of the emerging technologies like CRISPR in some of these,
uh,
genetic engineering technologies where they're starting to use non-viable human
fetuses and run some tests on them,
are you concerned at all about that?
Are you concerned about,
or I shouldn't need to use this term,
the term concern.
Cause obviously you're here to that mindset.
No,
no,
I'm good.
Things happen.
Oh No,
it's not just let things happen.
Let them watch what's going to happen.
Trying to anticipate the results,
understand them in detail,
anticipate what the results are and avoid negative ones to the extent you can.
But it's,
life is all about how things are going to change,
but accept the fact that things are gonna change and,
and,
and that's not,
that's,
that's are we happy that the world is different than it was during medieval
times?
Sure.
I mean except for,
you know,
Mike Pence and other people were,
the rest of us are happy or you know,
I can pick a lot of radio commentators,
but most of us are happy that we,
that the world has gotten a more open,
more interesting.
And so that's part of the human drama is that it's going to go places and we
don't know where it's gonna go and that's okay.
But we should all work as much as we can to try and make sure to the extent that
we can,
that the direction of heads is a good one.
Is,
is beneficial.
More interesting,
more exciting,
more possibilities,
more fun for everybody and,
and maybe even more sustainable because it seems reasonable that it should be
sustainable if we think we care about not just our children but our
grandchildren and their grandchildren.
And so that it's self interest in some sense to be interested in,
in conservation and sustainability instead of immediate profit if you really
care.
Of course,
you know,
might say,
if I amass enough wealth and my children will be fine forever and who gives a
damn about the rest of the People's children?
But you know,
we can decide that maybe it's in the best interest of,
of everyone if human societies sustainable because there'll be less likelihood
for extreme war,
extreme violence,
blah,
blah.
You can,
I would argue that we behave well in large part because of reason and,
and,
and my point is,
and I've had this though,
we had a session in my origins project,
a whole meeting on the origins of morality.
And,
and I've had this debate with a number of colleagues who point out,
I think it was [inaudible] who said you can't get ought from is okay,
you can't get off from is just by rationality.
You can't decide how to behave.
Maybe,
maybe.
But here's the point.
Without,
is you can never get dog without knowing the consequences,
your actions,
which is what science is all about.
You can't decide what's good and bad.
And so science and reason is an essential part of any progress because we can't
possibly decide what economic policies to enact or what or what social policies
are,
what it technological policies if we don't know the consequences of actions.
That's why,
for example,
she was an example.
It was so stupid for the Republicans to design this healthcare policy and
promoted before anyone analyze,
say the economic impact of it.
I mean they could have still decided to do it.
It's not as if but,
but at least that data would have been useful for making a final decision.
It's that simple.
Hmm.
What,
what,
I guess getting back to that CRISPR thing,
if that becomes available and if it advances to the point where it's available
to people that are alive today,
would would you,
would you give it a shot?
Would you change anything about yourself?
Would you become Thor?
I mean if it really gets to that point when we start,
we can worry about a lot of things when I'm not with me anywhere near as worried
about that as I'm hacking.
Right,
right.
Because if you know,
we can hack computers and if you can hack the DNA as a lot of kids want to do.
In fact,
I was told years ago,
I'm chairman of the board of something called the golden age of atomic
scientists that have the word of sponsors that sets the doomsday clock every
year.
And so we have to think about existential threats to mankind.
I remember about seven or eight years ago,
we had a,
a presser from MIT who said his computer science students were most interested
in hacking DNA,
much more interested than hacking because it's just an ad.
It's just a code,
right?
And so if you could manipulate arbitrarily in a very precise way,
DNA,
then of course there are many good things that can come and maybe you can make
yourself stronger,
bigger,
whatever you want.
Maybe we're not you,
maybe your children,
whatever.
And maybe you can overcome genetic diseases,
which of course would be great,
but you can also with,
you know,
with great power comes great responsibility.
And with that,
you can also imagine hacking,
right?
And creating new viruses or whatever you want.
And so,
yeah,
it's,
it's any new technology is terrifying.
Does that mean we shouldn't create new technologies?
I mean,
cars are terrifying.
Cars kill.
Look how many people cars can kill.
Now maybe you will have self driving cars,
maybe fewer people die.
Some people are afraid of that self driving cars because they do present moral
problems and up as if a car is designed to minimize the number of people that
kills.
And it can do that by killing you.
If you're faced with running into five school children or the car turning and
hitting a wall,
what do you want your car program to do?
And it's fascinating questions we will have to address.
But technology could,
so technology can be used in many ways and it's terrifying.
But uh,
it's,
it's trite to use this old expression,
but I do think of it at times,
which is that the little thing I gave him a stepdaughter once it said ships are
safe in the harbor.
But that's not what ships are meant to do.
I mean,
you can,
you can bury your head in the sand.
You can never go outside the house for fear of being run over by a car or being
embarrassed or whatever.
Or you can choose to live a life as your choice.
But to me,
living the life is as it is more interesting.
That's why in in the,
in the,
in the book I point out,
you can choose how to look at the world.
You can choose to say you're the center of the universe and if that makes you
feel better,
finding the universal was created for you.
Or you can choose to let your beliefs conform to the evidence of reality.
And,
and as soon the universe exists and evolved independent of your existence,
and in that case,
you're bound to be surprised.
Isn't it better to be able to have a life full of surprise and a life that
doesn't have any,
no.
It's a wonderful philosophy.
What I'm thinking is I'm wondering about these technological advancements when
it comes to the ability to manipulate the human body and when they get to the
point where we,
we don't have the same issues that we have today with diseases and when injuries
or even with a biological inferiorities with with everyone looks like Lebron
James.
Yeah,
yeah.
Okay.
That you could imagine that's the case.
I,
I suspect people will want different things and,
but okay,
that'll be a very different world.
But look at this way.
Um,
you're a pretty buff guy.
Okay.
You manipulated your body,
right?
Yes.
Okay.
What's wrong with that?
No,
nothing,
but I'm still five foot eight.
Okay.
The Lebron James is seven feet tall and he manipulated his body.
It's a very different deal.
If someone gives me a seven foot tall pill,
I might take it.
Yeah.
But you manipulate your body given the technology of the time changes and
everyone could be seven feet tall.
It was at worst because you can manage because you know enough physiology now or
whatever,
excess physiology that you can manipulate your body more efficiently now than
you could before.
And people can run faster miles or jump higher up because we've been sports
forever,
and so that's okay.
You know?
That's fine.
I'm just wondered what your thoughts are on the future.
Well,
these physiological imbalance,
I try to anticipate the possibilities and to the extent I can discuss what they
are so that we as a society could address them more cogently.
I do not,
however,
generally make predictions about anything less than 2 trillion years in the
future.
[inaudible].